so it's now being alleged that in that
infamous debate between donald trump and
joe biden during the 2020 presidential
campaign
shortly after which it was officially
announced that donald trump had coveted
it appears trump actually already had
coveted at the debate and knew it now
this is shocking in that trump would do
something so irresponsible that a
president would allegedly hide a
diagnosis of a very contagious disease
and risk exposing his opponent to the
disease it is shocking but it is not
surprising and uh we all suspected it at
the time that's the thing and we're
going to go back to some of those clips
um the report is in the guardian trump
tested positive for kovit a few days
before the debate chief of staff mark
meadows says in his new book
mark meadows makes a stunning admission
in his new memoir obtained by the
guardian saying a second test returned
negative donald trump tested positive
for kovit three days before his first
debate against joe biden there it is
mark meadows also writes that though he
knew each candidate was required to test
negative within 72 hours nothing was
going to stop trump from going out there
trump meadow says in the book returned a
negative result from a different test
shortly after the positive in other
words trump found a negative test
nonetheless the stunning revelation of
an unreported positive follows a year of
speculation about trump then 74
had the potentially deadly virus when he
faced biden 77 in cleveland on the 29th
of september remember trump announced he
had coveted on october 2nd
the white house said he announced the
result within an hour of receiving it
and he later went to the hospital
um donald trump is denying it
donald trump put out a statement
saying the story of me having coveted
prior to or during the first debate is
fake news in fact the test revealed i
did not have covid prior to the debate
now this could be a completely
meaningless statement and you just break
it down into its component parts and you
have to say well what how could what he
be saying maybe be
true but not the full truth
when trump says the story of me having
covid
is fake news he might be referring to
having symptomatic covid what he might
mean is listen before the debate i had a
positive test and a negative test but i
didn't have any symptoms and i didn't
really have it
until later that's what trump might mean
and he might be saying that out of
ignorance or he might be saying it out
of calculation trump also says a test
revealed i didn't have coveted prior to
the debate
right the story from mark meadows is he
got a positive test then he took a
different test than it was negative
and so
a test revealed i didn't have covet but
one test revealed that you did and of
course we all suspected that this was
the case as a reminder it's like it was
yesterday we had this video when trump
was in the hospital
dr sean connelly was asked when did
trump last test negative and i watched
this i think we had a stream with 60 70
000 people watching at the time we all
watched it together and his answer made
me say and it made many of you say
that is an evasive answer trump clearly
had coveted during the biden debate and
he knew it just as a reminder remember
this tell us when he had his last
negative test was it thursday was it
wednesday when do you remember when he
had his last negative
i don't want to go backwards
for people who are around him i
understand the contact tracing as i
understand it is being done
i'm not involved with that
so
very very suspicious
answer that made all of us think that's
obviously a lie and then this is from
this morning on cnn donald trump tested
positive for coronavirus three days
before his first debate against joe
biden on september 29 2020 the stunning
revelation is in a new book by former
white house chief of staff mark meadows
that was obtained by the guardian a
positive test the country never knew
about a positive test days before he
ultimately admitted to the country that
he had coveted and remember he didn't
look good or sound good during that
debate and many of you were saying in
the chat when we were streaming
something's wrong with trump right now
just before attending event after event
after event with vulnerable people now
there was a negative test the same day
but it still raises all kinds of
questions about honesty and transparency
and timing and why the white house chose
to trust one test rather than another
well he trusted the test that said
negative obviously for the debate
according to the guardian meadows writes
that he knew each candidate was required
to test negative for the virus within 72
hours of the start time but quote
nothing was going to stop trump from
going out there yeah you might also
remember that when trump
uh there was the story that trump
arrived too late to be tested
but on the honor system
trump's team said he got a negative test
today which may not have been wrong may
not have been a lie
but he also had a positive test so i
mean listen irresponsible is an
understatement and there's the personal
and there's the administrative and
policy
on policy trump was a disaster on kovid
we have reports that had he taken it
more seriously not said 15 cases will
soon be zero talked about masks you know
if he had if he had done all the right
things a significant number of the
deaths during 2020 could have been
prevented that we know at the policy
level
disbanded the pandemic response team you
guys know all the stories at this point
trump also was behaving irresponsibly at
the personal level and we knew that
intuitively we knew that when trump went
to a factory that requires masks
wore no mask but put on goggles
that was weird that was irresponsible uh
we we saw all the personal but this just
adds yet another layer to it and it is
not surprising because we all suspected
it at the time but it is shocking and
this is trump's own former chief of
staff saying it trump with a very
strange and narrowly worded denial i
believe mark meadows i don't think mark
meadows would make this up i don't know
why mark meadows would make this up and
uh it it was what we all suspected at
the time
your internet activity and data is being
observed by a variety of parties they're
selling your information they're
deciding what you can access don't let
it happen to you i use atlasvpn to keep
my internet traffic private from isps
tech platforms online marketers even
governments and atlas vpn keeps me
protected against hackers people
eavesdropping on networks to steal your
information if i turn on atlas vpn
before logging into netflix hulu or
amazon i can access streaming content
from other countries i can even watch
stuff from argentina like soccer i use
atlas vpn on all of my devices you
install it you turn it on once and then
you just forget about it and enjoy your
privacy you can read online about why
vpns are so important to use every day
really something you should have and
atlas vpn is having a huge sale giving
you 86 off comes out to like a dollar 39
a month for a subscription plus you'll
get three months free just go to atlas v
dot pn slash pacman the link is down
below